good morning
thank you for attending as you know
on wednesday this week the parliament
adopted the recovery and resilience
facility
the biggest building block on the next
of the next generation
eu recovery package this morning
president sasoli and prime minister
costa signed the legislative
act on behalf of the parliament
and the council in the presence of
president vanderlian
they will now comment on this following
which
there will be time for a few questions
president
prego
good morning at last
we have a twin engine a vaccine
to save lives and a vitamin
to boost economic recovery
now we need to accelerate vaccination
and is up to us to put recovery
in motion we are fighting
for health and jobs at present
looking into the future we are investing
today in climate action and the digital
transition
for the eu's next generation
this is the most innovative plan we have
ever had to manage the most challenging
crisis
we have ever faced now
we can be sure it's possible to
every decade covered and it's possible
to build a fair green and digital
recovery it's time to deliver
member states must conclude
the ongoing process of ratification of
the own resources decision
once this regulation is published next
week
we have to start the formal negotiations
of the national plans with the
commission
and the depth of the crisis calls for
urgent actions we must take up
the ambition to of having the first
plans approved
by the end of april
what our citizens expect
from us are concrete results
jobs prosperity well-being
we must all rise to the bold
and precedent and ambitious political
initiative
which brought together the commission
the parliament and the council we cannot
afford to waste more time we cannot
afford
to fail our citizens so
let's deliver
thank you very much first of all i would
like to congratulate council and
parliament for
the final adoption now of the regulation
this is indeed
a very historic moment as you said
antonio
we are fighting this pandemic and the
severe health crisis
with the vaccines the vaccines are ally
and hope
but we should never forget the second
enormous crisis we have this is the
economic crisis
and there our ally and our hope
is next generation eu 750 billion
750 billion to support our citizens to
keep
their jobs to support companies to stay
in business and to support communities
to maintain their social fabric
and this indeed next generation eu is
our
ally in this fight and it is our hope
in this fight it is also a unique
opportunity
for the member states to work together
on our priorities the european green
deal the digitalization
and resilience next generation is
more than money it is
a very strong message of
solidarity and of trust in the european
union
because what is true for the virus it's
also true
for the economy no member state on its
own
would have been possible to master this
economic crisis
just on its own and alone because our
single market is so deeply integrated
that we have to join forces and the
integration of the single market
is the basis of our prosperity
so joining forces enabling
the commission to raise money at the
capital market
and then together invest it in europe
that is an act of joint wisdom and an
act for trust in the european union
now indeed we have to honor that trust
so all three of us
are calling all on our member states to
ratify the own resources decision as
fast as possible
and in parallel of course we are working
intensely intensively to get
the national recovery plans ready so
it's time to deliver
indeed